hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the speed Chess
Championship semi-finals uh Hikaru
Nakamura versus nihal sarin we've
already seen one game and you guys said
okay uh Hikaru won the match we all know
that now uh and I show the game uh where
Nika won but the game that he won was
absolutely spectacular and I absolutely
had to show that one and even though I
will discuss what happened uh in the
match for for example here they play
like 30 games uh but I'm interested in
interested in the individual games like
and if someone won a match but did not
play any interesting games then someone
won like two very interesting games I
will show those two games that are very
interesting uh regardless of who won the
match uh so that's why I chose to show
nikal's game first but okay let's check
out one more uh this one's also very
nice as it features uh the age opening
and no it's not actually the Hikaru
opening although uh first I thought
that's why Hikaru chose to play it but
in the in the first game with the white
pieces that he had he opened with A3 now
the second game with white piece he
opens with H3 it's actually the Clemens
opening and Hikaru said that okay the
world the world rapid and Blitz
Championship is starting in 10 days uh
he doesn't want to uh you know over
stress himself over over this uh
speeches Championship he wants to enjoy
it he wants to you know casually uh uh
play it and uh that's why he didn't uh
you know just uh go for some top top
engine Theory uh but rather win for some
uh fun games with A3 and H3 uh but okay
still you have to play against him it is
Hikaru he's over 2 900 and nihal replies
with Ponte E5 and it's a very principle
the reply turn to the H Pawn as it grabs
the center and white really didn't do
all that much with the H Pawn and okay
C4 by Hikaru Knight to F6 with Knight to
C3 and Knight the C6 and already as of
move three we have a completely new game
Hikaru goes for G4 makes sense as you
already played H3 you might as well grab
more space with G4 preparing G5 so H6
and the bishop to G2 with Bishop to B4
and now Knight to F3 just preparing to
nicely Castle King side E4
uh nihal grabs more space in the center
uh this lodges the knight from F3 Knight
to H4 and now Pawn to D5 and okay uh
here Hikaru has to play something C
counters on D5 Knight captures and now
Bishop captures an E4 we have Knight
Bishop to E6 now adding a Defender to
the Knight and now Hikaru goes Knight to
F5 so Hikaru is up a pawn uh but he's uh
his position is objectively better but
it's very very hard to say I mean this
is completely new territory none of them
ever had this on the board and it's uh
Blitz it's five plus one uh it's
completely crazy so here nikal castles
A3 and now Bishop to C5 and uh here you
have to go Bishop to A5 with Bishop to
C5 you allow white to throw in this D4
move with Tempo and that just kickstarts
uh White's entire setup so here Pawn to
D4 Bishop to B6 and pawn to E3 now we
have rooked E8 by nihal and now uh hikar
Castle's King side and now you have to
decide how to go about this position do
you try to re-maneuver the Knight maybe
Knights the A5 then turn at the C4 or do
you move the Knight so maybe you gain
access to the B3 square or you're gonna
shift the Knight to the king side with
Knight E7 uh challenge the Knight on F5
maybe or even over the night the G6
nihal does none of that he goes Pawn to
H5 Hikaru already opened up his King and
nihal will try to take advantage of this
uh so uh H5 Bishop back to G2 and this
is a super classy move by Hikaru
basically he sees very far ahead into
the future and he knows that he needs
the E for move uh for for everything to
work and look at this now H characters
on G4 h-capped respond to G6 now attacks
the Knight Knight the H6 check King to
G7 attacks the Knight and now Pawn to E4
attacks the Knight on D5 and also
defends his Knight on H6 that's why
Bishop to G2 was such a such a strong
move so Knight captures on C3 B captures
and now Bishop to C4 goes after The Rook
here Rook the E1 and the queen to H4 and
look at nihal's position now the bishop
pair absolutely beautiful the queen
excellently placed on the H file the
rook and the E file the other will come
into D file uh seems like the the it's a
dream position but it only seems that
way in reality nikal doesn't really have
a a good move here he car replace G5 he
cements his Knight on H6 and now Rook 8
to d8 sort of fully completing his
development but hikar just plays Queen
to F3 and there is no way to increase
the pressure for knee-hull it's only it
only looks good but hikaru's Center is
so strong uh you you just can't do
anything against that so here uh the
problem is the the F6 square and even if
you move the king lets the king to H7 uh
you don't even have the capture on F7
you can play Knight G4 now you're gonna
get the Knight to F6 Fork the rook and
the King if you go back then Queen to F6
check is just a really really bad
position for nehal so instead he tries
Knight captures on D4 uh he opens up the
center and it's not bad okay giving up
one piece for two of those amazing
Central Pawns uh should be good C
captures on D4 Bishop captures on D4 and
now the Rook is also hanging on A1 but
Hikaru says I'm not interested in
material Bishop to F4 you can have your
Rook you've already given up one piece
uh and uh there's really nothing better
nihal grabs The Rook on A1 Hikaru
counters on A1 and now Nihao plays Queen
to H5 even though his position is
completely lost but he's also very low
on time he tried Queen to H5 but here he
blundered the bishop here Hikaru just
played Queen to C3 with check and he was
in this position and move 26 that nihal
sarin resigned to the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here uh so
really as this was uh the basically
hikaru's first win in the oh no maybe
we'll see Carl's second win let me just
check I don't want to trick you guys uh
let me just check real quickly
uh yeah this was uh hikaru's second win
in in the match but his first win with
the white pieces and it's very uh
interesting how he did it with Point H3
he he first the first game he tried uh
with Pawn to A3 but the Dead game ended
in a draw and if you guys are interested
in all the uh in all the sorry not that
in all the time uh formats uh here you
can see that in five plus one uh Hikaru
uh won five points nihal one three so he
car wins the five plus one section then
in three plus one it was equal and he
got really started fighting uh fighting
back four and a half to four and a half
but then in bullet again uh Hikaru was
better by two points five uh to three
and in the end uh Hikaru wins the match
with 14 and a half to ten and a half
which is uh a very very close and uh by
far the best anyone did against Hikaru
in this speeches championship match as
you can see uh paravian scored seven and
a half points against Hikaru aronyan
scored eight and a half and uh nihal
sarin scored 10 and a half against
Hikaru and now Hikaru is in the finals
waiting for the winner of the match
Magnus Carlson versus Maxime martial
lagrav which will be taking place today
so we'll see who wins and who will face
Hikaru in the finals uh so yeah uh
Hikaru already won four speeches
championships so this will be his fifth
attempt and we'll see if if he can do it
or or he will will he go all out against
the Magnus if he wins if Magnus wins
against the mvl or will he play against
nihal maybe some A3 maybe some H3 stuff
and save whatever he has prepared for
the uh World rapid and Blitz
Championship that will be taking place
uh I think from 26th to 30th of of
December
uh sure uh that's the game and a little
bit of extra info about the match hope
you guys enjoyed that and uh just
because someone plays H3 against you
doesn't know it's necessarily a bad move
like it it's bad if your opponent plays
absolute perfect moves but you know
you're You're Gonna Play G4 you're gonna
think yeah to your Bishop you're gonna
win the full Center like Hikaru in the
black uh black could be very well
struggling for his life the the entire
game like like was the case here uh so I
once again hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Chris Robert Picard
sapon bati on Sarah Hamilton
um uh Jonathan hirsche in quote box for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day